would fan favorite actor anya taylor
joyff hit the role of harley quinn and
is there a chance she could ever play
the lovable troublemaker keep watching
for one vision of what this fascinating
take on the character could look like
sometimes it's fun to imagine what your
favorite actor would look like if they
took on a famous role if you've ever
imagined say the punisher star jon
bernthal as two-face or speculated about
what carnage might look like months
before venom let there be carnage was
released in theaters then you know what
it's like to want to see a certain
performer in a specific comic book role
fortunately online fan arts can
sometimes scratch that itch like say if
you wanted to see one of your favorite
actors as harley quinn harley first
appeared on batman the animated series
and has become a comic book superstar in
the following years she's been brought
to life in live action multiple times in
recent years by margot robbie after
debuting in the role in 2016's suicide
squad robbie has since appeared as
harley in both 2020s birds of prey and
2021's the suicide squad robbie seems to
be happy in the role and there's no
reason to believe anyone will be
replacing her as the dceu version of the
character anytime soon
consider this your first lesson
pain is for dummies
that said it's still fun for fans to
speculate about what other performers
could bring to potential other versions
of the role one fan on instagram has
transformed dania taylor joy known for
the queen's gamut and the witch among
many other high profile projects into dr
harleen quinzel and the end result is
quite a stunning work of art the fan art
was created by eloluzianista.cl
a digital artist who works in multiple
mediums including photography digital
photo manipulations and traditional art
they also do tattoos in this instance
their portrait of taylor joy as harley
quinn is a digital manipulation of a red
carpet photo of the actor the fan art
shows taylor joy covered in quinn's
iconic white face paint with red and
blue eyeshadow while a single tear
smears the makeup under her left eye
quinn's signature black and white
ruffled costume is also visible in the
frame along with one of her black
leather gloves over her head and neon
crown hovers barely visible in the
background is a pattern of laughter
colored in different shades of red and
purple all of which is to say that the
image does a compelling job of selling
taylor joy as someone who could play a
believable harley quinn whether or not
that will ever actually happen is of
course a total mystery it wouldn't be
the first time taylor joy has stepped
into the role of a comic book character
though she made her first foray into the
superhero genre when she played ileana
rasputin also known as magic in 2020's
new mutants while the rotten tomato
score indicates the film was not quite
as well received as some of her other
projects it didn't steer her away from
the world of blockbuster filmmaking
taylor joy is set to play a younger
version of charlize theron's furiosa in
a mad max fury road prequel centered
around the beloved character it's clear
taylor joy definitely isn't afraid of
taking on iconic roles which means
there's always a chance she could play
harley quinn one day she's already got a
pretty good sense of humor
for those of you who didn't see it what
were you doing on quarantine
it was tiger king and queen scampi that
was the only new tv for like months
the offer would obviously have to be
right for that to happen of course and
it might be awkward for there to be
multiple live-action film harleys at the
same time but then again there have been
multiple jokers over the past few years
director matt reeves has officially
kick-started a new dc comics film
franchise with the batman and it's set
in a different reality than the dc eu in
which robbie's harley quinn operates
reeves has confirmed that a version of
the joker played by barry keoghan
already exists in the world of the
batman so the door has been opened for
reeves to introduce a version of harley
quinn in a future sequel or spin-off tv
show if that ever happens taylor joy is
certainly someone worth considering as
this piece of fan art proves check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite comic book characters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you